- Our next guests are all about
sharing the horror stories
and highlights of being a mom
with their podcast book and comedy tour,
I Mom So Hard.
Let's welcome Kristin
Hensley and Jen Smedley.
Give it up y'all!
(scary music)
(child scream effect)
- Wow!
- We're quadruplets, amazing.
- [Kelly] Come on.
(Kelly laughing)
- They put me in Spanx,
which is the scariest
part of this costume.
- Oh my God, this was
my one costume I didn't,
so I'm not wearing Spanx. I'm happy.
- I am like a sausage right now.
- I am so free right now,
just living my best flabby life.
- You all have pretty costumes.
- Yeah, you guys look cool.
- Well this is Lonnie, this is Rose,
and you guys, this is awesome.
This is great.
- The Shining.
- We're the twins from The Shining.
- Yeah, but we're more
like the Irish twins
'cause I'm so short. Like
she's the older sibling.
- [Kristin] Irish twins
are actually way scarier
than the Shining twins.
Because if you have
Irish twins, well done.
- [Jen] You haven't slept in a long time.
- You haven't slept, but
you slept one time...
Too many times.
(laughs)
- So wait, are you ready for Halloween?
Like with the kiddos tonight?
- We can't wait.
I'm a big Halloween fan, and
we always go to Kristin's house
'cause she has this amazing
Halloween neighborhood.
- Yes.
- And so it's our tradition
that we get the families
together and we trick or treat.
And I also have this tradition
of losing one of my children
in her neighborhood.
So let's see if it goes every
year four in a row. Yeah.
- But they're getting
older, so now we're like,
"They're gonna want their
candy. They're gonna come back."
- [Kelly] They're gonna come back.
- You know.
- [Kelly] It's like dogs,
they know that you feed them.
- [Kristin] Right.
- [Kelly] Aww, they're so cute.
- [Kristin] I Know.
Mine's in middle school.
I'm like, if you get lost
for three days since-
I'm just kidding.
It's fine.
- So wait, how's the comedy tour going?
- It's going really well.
We're towards the end of our third tour,
which is pretty crazy.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's busy.
- It is busy,
and we have a few shows
left in the Chicago area,
and then we are taking a break,
and we won't tour again
until late into 2023.
So we get to be home
with kids and families
and then it gives us a little
time to wanna leave again.
- [Jen] Get caught up on life,
do our Christmas shopping.
That won't happen.
- We won't do that.
- We'll wait 'til the last minute.
- We'll wait.
- We will.
- So wait, so for the past few Halloweens
we've done a digital series
that's featured some truly,
truly creepy toddler stories, like this.
(scary music)
"When my son was two years old,
he started to name new toys
with the name Joe.
Stuffed animal, dog, pet fish, et cetera.
And we named all of them Joe, I guess.
We thought it was an odd
name for a child to use
for his pet fish, but just went with it.
Then he had told me he
no longer wanted to sleep
with his stuffed dog.
He told me it was because the lights play
with it at night and he
doesn't like the lights.
Shortly after we found
out that an old man died
in our house and yes, his name was Joe.
Oh no!
Nope. Nope.
And that's when I move.
- [Jen] Tunk! Tunk! Tunk! For sale.
- Yeah, no.
I don't do, I'm not like
excited about that lifestyle.
So today with-
No one is, why did I say it like that?
Okay. So today with the
help of Kristen and Jen,
we are bringing you
more creepy kids stories
sent in by moms across the nation.
So let's grab our flashlight
and get ready to be scared.
Here we go.
Jen, you've got the
first creepy kiddo story.
So, and this is yours.
- Well, this story's extra creepy
because it's my actual
daughter that did it.
So a few years ago we
moved into a new house,
and a few weeks in she said,
"Have you seen the purple
people walking around the house
Mom?"
And I said, "No baby,
what do they look like?"
And she said, "Well they
wear these long purple gowns
and they have crowns on their head
and they're kind of see through.
But don't worry," she said,
"They won't do anything bad to you."
I always assume that my houses are built
on like a sacred burial
ground or something like that.
And that they're cursed
'cause why wouldn't they be?
And I said, "Well, why
are they here baby?"
And she said, "Come here.
They're here for daddy."
(haunting music)
- [Kelly] What?!
- So if anybody wants to
buy a three-two in Tarzano,
I'll give you a great deal on it.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God. "They're here for for daddy."
- They're here for for daddy.
- Did you tell your husband this?
- Yeah I told him, Yeah.
- "You better look out."
- Purple robes.
That sound like my church choir.
(audience laughing)
- So wait, Lonnie, you've
actually got the next one.
- Oh okay. All right.
- Oh, work that with those nails.
- Okay, here we go.
Here's a viewer story
from a mom named Allie.
"When my daughter was two years old,
we walked past her daycare's old garage."
Sorry for the one fang.
"Every day she would look up the stairs
of the window of the garage and wave.
One day I asked her who she was waving at,
and she turned to me and smiled
while shrugging and said, 'Pete.'
I was freaked out, but let it drop.
Until years later when my
son, who was two and a half,
we drove by the same
window to drop him off.
He'd never been there before.
He looks up at the window
waves and says softly.
'Hi Pete.'
(haunting music)
And that was the end of that daycare!
- That kinda stuff, oh man!
I wish you really hope it's not real.
Okay. Time for one more.
This is my turn.
- All right. Come on Kelly!
- Here we go.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- It's getting spooky.
Okay, here we go.
Okay. So this is weird to
see your face like that.
Okay. This is from Kelly
Kimball on my staff.
Okay.
"Charlotte, my daughter
had a bunch of friends
and families over to celebrate
her fifth grade graduation.
Okay. As I was passing out pieces of cake,
I asked her friend Summer to
go count how many more pieces
of cake we needed.
Summer comes back and
says, I think just one more
unless the lady with the
red hair wants a piece.
Bewildered, I asked her 'What lady?'
And she said, 'The one in the
guest house wearing white.'"
What?
"My mom had passed away
a few years earlier
in the guest house.
I showed summer a photo of my
mom and asked, 'This lady?'
And she said, 'Yes.'"
(haunting music)
What?!
- That was grandma coming to visit.
- I know, but should
grandma just stay away?
Like I just, I just feel like
grandma should stay away.
I feel like we had our time, right?
Like I, that creeps me out.
Oh my gosh.
And then a part of me is like,
do you run out there to
see if you can see her
and have a talk?
Like what do you do?
Like, I don't know.
- I think you talk to Summer
and you say, "Quit keeping tabs
on how much cake everybody's eating."
(everybody laughs)
It's a party okay.
- Nobody likes that person.
- Yeah.
- All right.
And that's creepy kids
stories around the campfire.
Check out the I Mom So hard podcast
wherever you get your podcast guys.